[Music]
uh you guys must be new to town right
new to town but not new to the country
we just moved from California oh we just
wondered uh if you wouldn't mind if your
daughter played with our daughter Audrey
say hi
why
slides off limits to Ching chongs
cute
do you want to be best friends look at
me look at me look at me now guess who's
going back to the motherland it's a big
deal going to your birth country we used
to talk about it all the time when we're
little remember Grand Adventure to find
your birth mother so proud of you
y'all calling me crazy my translator in
Beijing Audrey I got you ready
[Laughter]
Pat lives there now your famous college
roommate are you ready to lose to a
celebrity
where did that come from
you know I think I get it I called the
adoption agency and she lives in hygiene
okay will you guys come with me [__] yes
[__] I love a grand adventure
oh hi so nice to see an American what do
you do for work it's the cops are doing
a back check
you're drug dealers now [__] what the
[__] is that a condom we can't get
caught with drugs in China we'll get
jailed for life
never come to China people are always
thinking that I have this perfect life I
don't belong anywhere if you do not know
where you come from how do you know who
you are
we can still find her our passports are
in my suitcase that got stolen you know
we can bypass the airport security K-pop
Stars everyone remember their names
sassy cutie Lisa Lisa too I don't
believe these girls are singers girls
show them
um
you're a fan of cardi B right yeah but
is she here
there's some [__] in this house
there's some holes
did you get the coke bags out yeah but
only seven and I think I put an eight
just push pull I mean twice
it's not up to my [__]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]